[Applause]
over
and over and over again
as england are peaking at the euros that
song
is back
it's 25 years since bedeal and skinner
produced it with ian brody
of the lightning seeds and even he's
thinking
it might finally happen started to
believe more and more and more
i'm in i'm totally in you know you're
having conversations with people you
know
don't know anything about football but
they're quoting details
you know they don't understand and i
love that you know i know
i i just love that and i think that's
that's really the moment is that when
when it draws in all the people who
don't usually pay any attention to
football
that's that's kind of the moment isn't
it when you know the whole country's
there
the players have been relaxing doing
whatever floats their unicorns
there is though more focus in training a
semi-final demands it
denmark are strong driven on by what
happened to christian eriksen who
collapsed on the pitch
in their opening game gareth southgate
will
have a plan and however much he's
questioned
so far he's got it right he probably
sits here and gives us all the plot it
says players but we appreciate the job
that he's doing and the way that he sets
us up and
his man management skills so no i i
can't speak highly enough of gareth and
and his coaching staff and and the way
that we he's gone about his business
over the last four years
maguire was a toddler in that summer of
96 when england fans were convinced
it was going to happen they are now back
in that sweet spot
of just maybe tom parmenter
sky news